Welcome to our year-end review, part two.
If you’re tuning in for the first time,
this is a special episode during which we
give you one headline from every country in
the world from the past year.
The caveat is, hopefully, it’s a headline
you hadn’t heard, and has little to do with
the C-word.
We did this last year, and we organized countries
by population size, counting down from largest
to smallest.
This year, we are doing a count-up organized
by the Human Development Index, which is a
number between 0 and 1 determined by the United
Nations based on a series of metrics including
education, longevity, and earnings.
We are halfway through the list, and we’ll
end with the country that has the highest
HDI in the world.
If you haven’t watched part one, we suggest
you do that too, where we explain the HDI
breakdown in detail.
If you’re joining for part two, thanks,
because it means you liked part one.
Without delay, here’s two.
Distancing themselves is something that a
Dutch organization is trying to do with Astrid
Roemer, a poet from the former Dutch colony
of Suriname, after it awarded her with a prestigious
literary prize earlier this year.
Recently, she made controversial statements
supporting murderous former president of Suriname
Desi Bouterse, and the Dutch organizers of
the award chose to forego the ceremony honoring
her, and simply gave her the cash prize with
little fanfare.
Roemer, like any real poet, is sticking to
her words.
Back underground we go, this time to Petite
Mustique, which is part of Saint Vincent and
the Grenadines, where a human skull was unearthed
on this remote, rugged island in 2003.
And, this year, researchers at the University
of Oregon may have uncovered why it was there:
Skeletal abnormalities show the female likely
had leprosy, and this isolated part of the
Caribbean was probably used to keep people
with the disease away from the public—something
that many have speculated but this finding
actually supports.
The skull dates back 200 years and is possibly
the earliest case of leprosy recorded in the
Americas.
There is also some speculation that Tunisian
president Kais Saied’s appointment of a
female prime minister may have been a way
to calm critics who say he’s overreaching
his power in the Arab Spring’s only remaining
democracy.
Before Najla Bouden Ramadhane’s appointment,
Saied had already suspended parliament, seized
power, and fired the previous prime minister,
and because Ramadhane doesn’t have a lot
of political experience, her trajectory could
be challenging.
But, she is already making history as the
first female prime minister in the Arab world.
The Maldives have the unenvious position of
exemplifying climate change’s already dire
effects on low-lying nations, where 30% of
the country’s annual government budget is
being spent on adapting to climate change.
Developed nations have agreed to spend $100
billion to help vulnerable countries adapt,
but Maldives speaker of parliament wants more;
he’s asking that rich nations also pay reparations
to help the others deal with the consequences
they’re already suffering—and likely didn’t
cause.
Islands in the Caribbean continue to bet big
on tourism, especially countries like Dominica
which offers Citizenship-by-Investment through
properties like the six-star resort of Secret
Bay.
For the fifth year in a row, Dominica was
named the Best Country for Second Citizenship
by Professional Wealth Management magazine.
The second-home citizens have primarily come
from Africa, but with a new nonstop flight
from Miami running, that could potentially
change with Americans starting to look south
for another home—and passport.
Added bonus: Dominican residents now get visa-free
access to China.
When we say coral reef, you probably say,
ugh.
That’s because a lot of news about the ocean’s
critical habitat for fish species is generally
bad.
And that could have been the expectation after
Tropical Cyclone Winston caused more than
$1.4 billion in damage to Fiji in 2016 and
pummeled the island’s reefs.
But, they’ve bounced back in a big way as
young coral colonies have taken off, much
to the delight of researchers, residents,
and likely the colorful fish that have found
a new home.
Also in repair are more than a handful of
the 130 precious, historical artifacts that
were destroyed in the harbor blast in Lebanon
that killed 200 people.
While the objects pale in comparison to human
lives, their historical significance remains
important and that’s why the British Museum
granted $29,500 in restoration funds to help
repair some of the more critical glass vessels
which are nearly 2,000 years old.
Over on the northwest tip of Africa, an ongoing
conflict between Algeria and Morocco might
leave Spain in the cold.
Spain gets about half of its gas from Algeria,
which pumps it through a pipeline in Morocco.
Morocco depends on Algeria for about 10% of
its gas, and Algeria suspended this pipeline
to both countries to upset Morocco in an ongoing
territorial dispute.
It turns out, this may affect Spainiards the
most who will still be able to get gas through
alternate routes but at much higher prices.
Moldova is running out of gas too.
At the end of its contract with Gazprom, Moldova
declared a state of emergency when the Russian
energy company raised its gas prices and slashed
supply.
Accused of using gas as leverage, allegations
have surfaced that contract renegotiations
involved discussion of political issues regarding
Moldova’s separatist region of Transnistria
and its connection to the EU.
Associated with the EU, but reliant on Russian
resources, Moldova frequently finds itself
in the unenviable position of sitting between
east and west.
From unenviable to regrettable, a mafia fugitive
did himself in by appearing on a YouTube cooking
show in his adopted home of the Dominican
Republic.
Though he never showed his face while flashing
his Italian culinary chops, Marc Feren Claude
Biart’s tattoos gave him away to the police.
A member of Italy’s largest mafia who fled
Europe when accused of trafficking cocaine
into the Netherlands, Biart led a quiet, unassuming,
and, in hindsight, too comfortable life in
the city of Boca Chica.
An apocalyptic scene unfolded just off the
coast of Azerbaijan as a column of fire blasted
out of the Caspian Sea.
While the Caspian is dotted by various offshore
oil rigs, the assumed culprit for the flare
up wasn’t a leaky Soviet-era pipeline, but
one of the region’s infamous mud volcanoes
sparking the blast.
Dubbed the “Land of Fire,” Azerbaijan
is home to major oil reserves and hundreds
of these mud volcanoes—many of which are
active today.
What happens underground is also of interest
in St. Lucia, where the Caribbean nation is
taking the first steps towards harnessing
geothermal energy.
Currently, St. Lucia relies primarily on diesel
generators for power, so any alternative that
would alleviate high energy costs is welcomed,
especially one as green as geothermal.
The next step is figuring out viability—a
project that will be greatly aided by a $22
million grant made by the World Bank to explore
the potential of the energy source.
In Ecuador’s most famous islands, Darwin’s
Arch died of natural causes.
Just a kilometer, or 0.6 miles, off the coast
of Darwin Island in the Galapagos, the arch
was a popular destination for divers and photographers.
Ecuadorian officials said that the bridge
was brought down by natural erosion.
Year by year, though, erosion is becoming
more of a threat and less natural, as volatile
weather and warming waters are intensifying
the process that created many of the earth’s
arches in the first place.
Another troubling trend came to a head in
China.
Birthrates in the world’s most populous
country hit an all-time low since the country
began tabulating the figure in 1978.
Infamous for its “one child” policy, China
has been easing restrictions on family-size
since 2015 as dropping birth rates began to
worry state officials.
This year’s low water mark, though, hints
that the problem may be beyond policy and
expected demographic shifts as the country
develops, and more so a function of rising
cost of living and financial insecurity pushing
potential parents to hold off.
Birds, too, are adapting to changing material
living conditions.
A study of 77 non-migratory birds undertaken
in Brazil has shown that each species has
become smaller in stature over the past 40
years.
This finding in species confined to remote
areas of the Amazon has allowed researchers
to conclude that the shrinking is in response
to the one major alteration in their environment:
temperature rise.
While researches haven’t come to a consensus,
it’s hypothesized that the birds are slimming
down because they simply aren’t required
to generate the same body heat as in decades
prior––humans are doing it for them.
A decision made by Colombia’s congress gave
Viche, often referred to as “African-Colombian
Moonshine,” its well-deserved moment in
the sun.
Recognizing the liquor distilled from sugar
cane by generations of African Colombians
as a piece of the country’s “ancestral
and cultural heritage,” is an honor, and
for many, an opportunity.
Increased notoriety, experts believe, will
provide an opportunity for distillers to capitalize
on the product–giving it the chance to follow
the same trajectory as Mezcal in Mexico and
to create generational wealth locally.
While other parts of former Yugoslavia threatened
to fall apart, North Macedonia celebrated
2021 as the year marked the 30th anniversary
of its peacefully-established independence.
A military parade through the capital of Skopje
and celebrations across the country marked
the occasion.
While independent for decades, integration
into the West has been a winding road as disputes
with Greece saw the country relinquish its
original name, Macedonia, for its current
moniker.
Another milestone was reached this year when
Joe Biden became the first US President to
acknowledge that the Armenian Genocide was
in fact a genocide.
In Armenia, and across the Armenian diaspora,
the news was welcomed with a tepid response
not because of the 106 years of separation
from the event, but because the declaration
is, of course, merely a declaration.
Many see the statement as a symbolic gesture
designed to test the relationship with Turkey
who has yet to qualify the historical atrocity
as a genocide.
A move that may have large repercussions caught
the eye of free speech advocates world-wide
when Thailand’s government banned the dissemination
of news that “causes public fear.”
The government framed the mandate as a move
to limit the dangerous spread of disinformation
but critics see it differently.
The ban, which allows the government to block
individual’s internet access, conveniently
materialized just as criticism with the government’s
slow rollout of vaccines hit fever pitch.
For Peru’s conservative right, there’s
been no escaping fear-inducing news in 2021,
as a narrow election saw the swearing in of
socialist president Pedro Castillo.
The rise of the rural teacher-turned-politician
caught the world off guard and certainly didn’t
sit well with the country’s established
power brokers who immediately contested the
result and whose supporters harassed election
officials.
Only months in, Castillo’s presidency is
barely holding on as his approval rating has
plummeted and a possible move to impeach hangs
in the balance.
A world record also hung in the balance this
year as spectators along an Antiguan harbor
anxiously awaited the appearance of Jasmine
Harrison’s rowboat on the horizon.
She and her boat eventually pulled into the
waters of Antigua and Barbuda, the nation
that marks the finish line of the Talisker
Whiskey Atlantic Challenge, and Harrison became
the youngest woman to row the Atlantic solo—a
70-day-long odyssey that saw her thrown overboard
twice and her mettle tested constantly.
Coming to the end of their own odyssey is
the “Scythian Gold.”
This year, A Dutch court ruled that the trove
of Crimean treasures dating back to the days
of the Silk Road rightfully belonged to Ukraine.
On display in 2014 when Russia annexed the
peninsula, the fate of these cultural artifacts
had been in limbo for years before this ruling.
Russia has criticized the ruling, while Ukraine
has labeled it another recognition of the
world’s condemnation over Russia’s seizure
of the peninsula.
In Saint Kitts and Nevis, the story’s apiculture.
Now if you aren’t a former geo-bee champion
with an expansive vocabulary, you may not
recognize the place nor the practice.
All the same, the Caribbean nation of 50,000
joined an international effort to help launch
and support local bee-keeping businesses.
If properly executed, the initiative will
create additional jobs, bring local honey
and wax products to market, and help protect
biodiversity by keeping pollinators, well,
buzzing.
West of where a bulk of bees are set to soon
buzz, Mexican politicians and activists battled.
After much debate, it was announced that Mexico’s
150-year-old Columbus statue was to be replaced
by a statue of an indigenous woman.
A reasonable decision at surface level, and
one that recognizes two oft-overlooked groups
in Mexico, women and indigenous people, some
see the move as political posturing by Mayor
Claudie Sheinbaum—one that wins her positive
PR without actually helping the plight of
indigenous Mexicans or women.
From statues in metaphorical hot water to
those physically under it, Grenada announced
the completion of a renovation to its underwater
sculpture park.
Repairs and cleaning of already existing sculptures
were part of the project, but the most exciting
bit was the new 82-piece installation celebrating
Grenadian culture.
Since its creation in 2006, the park has offered
habitat for marine wildlife and served as
an important tourist draw—the renovation
aims to maintain that positive momentum.
Though hard to imagine, things are getting
more complicated in a country with two names
and three presidents.
Calling it an “existential threat,” one
top American diplomat flew to Bosnia-Herzegovina
to coax Bosnian Serb leader, Milorad Dodik,
to lighten his separatist rhetoric that, if
acted upon, would potentially nose-dive the
nation and destabilize the region.
The epicenter of ethnic violence in the mid-1990s
that took painstaking negotiations to quell,
a separatist move like the one Dodik threatens
would set the region back decades.
If nothing else good came of it, the pandemic
offered zoo animals a well-earned rest.
In Sri Lanka, where zoos closed in March of
2020 and have only briefly opened since, animals
have taken the newfound peace and quiet to
deepen relationships and spend a lot of time
in bed.
The result was a baby boom, as some species—the
black swan and white peacock—mated in Sri
Lankan zoos for the first time ever, while
others such as lions, have accelerated their
output in lieu of nosey-onlookers.
Perhaps the world could’ve used a few more
nosey onlookers in the Sea of Oman this year
as noted not-friends Iran and the US offered
wildly different accounts as to what really
happened when Iran seized an oil tanker just
off its coast.
Iran officials claimed that the US had taken
their tanker before their successful naval
assault reclaimed the ship, while US officials
say that it was a Vietnamese tanker that Iran
had seized.
Regardless of who’s telling the truth, this
most recent rift offers a reminder of just
how rocky the relations between the two nations
remain.
Cuban officials wouldn’t be fooled twice
this year.
After the largest protests in 30 years caught
them off guard this July, the government made
sure to stamp out the next protest before
it even started.
As news spread of a potential pro-democracy,
freedom of expression demonstration, the state
didn’t let noted protesters leave their
homes, arrested congregators, and released
media claiming that protests were an attempt
of regime change by the hands of the US.
One European country has proved especially
welcoming to Afghan refugees, and it’s one
of the continent’s poorest.
Albania, bolstered by a culture familiar with
and receptive to immigrants, pledged to take
in as many as 4,000 Afghans.
The nearly 700 that made it to the coastal
nation were put up in beach-side resorts.
Albania is likely just a year-long stop for
refugees as they seek to secure visas to countries
that offer more opportunity, but Albania has
made it clear that they’re more than welcome
to stay should they want to.
Michael B. Jordan understands firsthand the
baggage that comes with a name.
Perhaps that’s why the actor was willing
to change the name of his new rum brand, initially
called “J’Ouvert” once Trinidad and
Tobagonians took offense to his trademarking
the term that refers to the opening of their
famed Carnival.
Labeling the act as cultural appropriation,
thousands from Trinidad and Tobago signed
an online petition to protect and respect
a word that means so much to their culture
The Coco de Mer, a palm tree that produces
the world’s largest—and subjectively,
the most inappropriate—seed in the world,
only exists in Seychelles.
In fact, the tree only grows on two of the
archipelago’s 115 islands while the rare
seed, sold mostly to bemused tourists, fetches
up to $260.
Beloved by islanders, heavily regulated by
the government, and yet still endangered,
Seychelles is taking a new approach to conserving
the tree by putting seeds in the hands of
locals.
Those interested in growing the tree on their
property can apply for the honor and must
prove they have enough room and the right
soil for the palm to take off.
Sending mail to the Chagos archipelago became
a bit more difficult this year.
Recognizing Mauritius' sovereignty over the
chain of islands that’s now one of Britain’s
last and most controversial colonial holdings,
the UN’s postal union decided it would no
longer recognize postage stamps issued by
the “British Indian Overseas Territories
of the UK.”
This move adds ever so slightly to the pressure
on Britain to leave the chain and represents
another baby step towards returning home for
Chagossians forcibly relocated to Mauritius
decades ago.
Cristiano Ronaldo couldn’t wait to get home
after a controversial call in Serbia cost
him and his country important World Cup qualifying
points.
However, throwing his captain’s armband
down in disgust as he exited the pitch unintentionally
did a world of good for a six-month-old Serbian
boy with spinal muscular atrophy.
Donated to a charity group who then auctioned
off the armband, Ronaldo’s frustration resulted
in a $71,000 haul—money which went directly
to the six-month-old’s treatment.
In Kuwait, things aren’t looking quite as
dire for those nearing the other end of the
age spectrum as the country’s legislature
reversed a ban on employing expatriates over
the age of 60.
Struck down because it had no legal basis,
the ruling serves as just a respite for the
nation’s expat population who have been
leaving by the thousands as the state continues
to push for the development of its domestic
workforce through its years-long “Kuwaitization”
project.
A more substantial legal ruling was recorded
this year in Malaysia as the country’s highest
court ruled that the Islamic provision that
banned same sex acts was unconstitutional.
LGBTQ advocates have called the ruling “historic”
as the country’s experienced an uptick in
homophobic sentiment in recent years.
This ruling though, does not legalize same-sex
acts, as a civil law from Britain’s colonial-era
banning those is still on the books.
Costa Rica earned some well-deserved national
attention when the country was named one of
the five winners of the Earthshot Prize—a
global sustainability effort spearheaded by
Prince William and Kate Middleton.
Financed largely by taxes on fossil fuels,
Costa Rica has handed more than $500 million
to landowners over the last 20 years to protect
forests and watersheds.
The effort has largely reversed deforestation
in the country.
While the prize money is nice, the international
recognition serves as a proof of concept for
other nations and a pat on the back for forward-thinking
Costa Rica.
Forward-thinking was the praise Georgia thought
it might reap when the country broke ground
on its “hypermodern” parliament building
a decade ago.
Today though, it sits empty, and its glass
windows meant to signal governmental transparency
gather dust.
Done in by its distance from the capital and
the new political regime’s distaste for
it, the building was abandoned in 2018, then
put up for sale through May of 2021, when
the government finally gave up on finding
a buyer.
As Georgia gave up on its governmental greenhouse,
Oman announced their aim to build a massive
green hydrogen plant.
Oman’s following the forward-thinking theme
by working to smooth an impending economic
transition, as 85% of the country’s GDP
is generated from oil and gas—resources
which the country’s quickly running out
of.
Powered by wind and solar, it is hoped that
the $30 billion project will be producing
and exporting renewable energy at full capacity
by 2038.
In the very same year that Barbados ended
symbolic ties with the Queen of England and
became a republic, the nation’s most famous
export, Rihanna, became a national hero.
Well, technically the artist, entrepreneur,
and proud bajan has been a national icon in
the country for more than a decade, but this
year her legendary status became official
when the new republic’s prime minister designated
her a national hero.
Already an ambassador for the Caribbean country,
and recently named the world’s richest female
musician, it seems that Rihanna’s reign
just won’t let up–and Barbados is all
the better for it.
At the other end of the Caribbean, three Cubans
survived 33 days on a barren Bahamian island
before being rescued by the US Coast Guard.
After capsizing at sea, likely in an attempt
to flee Cuba, the three washed up on one of
the least-hospitable Bahamas, surviving on
coconut water, conch shells, and rats.
After receiving brief medical attention in
Florida, the resourceful survivors were handed
over to US Immigration and Customs Enforcement.
This isn’t the first time The Bahamas have
found itself as the meeting point between
Cuban defectors and the US, as a similar rescue
took place a few islands over not months before
this one.
The Bahamas have hardly been the focal point
for dangerous American migrations, though.
It’s been a record-breaking year for Panama
immigration officials as a whopping 70,000
migrants from around the world have passed
through the Darien Gap and into the country.
Such incredible numbers making their way through
the undeveloped, densely forested, and crime-riddled
route with no formal roadways has pushed Panamanian
and Colombian officials to begin regulating
the number of entrants into the Darien Gap—potentially
a first step in making the journey safer for
the desperate migrants.
International collaboration was the context
that informed an embarrassing development
in Bulgaria.
Led by the US Army, the NATO military exercise
called Swift Response brought together 7,000
paratroopers from 10 member nations for some
joint practice.
Swift Response, though, quickly became seriously
regrettable when American soldiers accidently
left the training zone and barged into and
cleared out a Bulgarian sunflower oil factory.
The factory has since filed a lawsuit, while
the US embassy, for its part, has apologized
for the mistake.
Netflix further expanded its reach when it
greenlit the company’s first feature-length
film shot in Uruguay.
The company’s VP of Latin American content
has hailed the project as an exciting opportunity
to highlight the creative talent in the country.
While it’s unlikely that viewers will recognize
names when the credits roll, the film, titled
Togo, will fit right in the current cinematic
canon as the crime drama revolves around street-level
drug trafficking and organized crime.
Following the appearance of mysterious metallic
monoliths across the American West and in
Romania, a similar structure appeared in southwest
Turkey.
But this one came with a message in ancient
Turkish: “look at the sky, and you will
see the moon.”
Residents didn’t have to wait long on an
explanation as to the origins of the structure
and its innocuous truism though, as only days
after its discovery, President Erdoğan used
the monolith as a background when he announced
the country’s new space program and 10-year
vision—proving the monolith’s function
as an eye-rolling gimmick.
Bucking tradition at the Tokyo Olympics, one
sprinter, rather than running for her country,
ran away from it.
Accusing her coaches of negligence before
being pulled from her event and pressured
to return home to Belarus, Krystsina Tsimanouskaya
fled to the Polish embassy where she was granted
a humanitarian visa.
The incident exemplifies the mounting pressure
on Belarussian public figures under the country’s
increasingly authoritarian government as she
joins a growing list of athletes, coaches,
and high-profile Belarussians that have faced
job loss, arrest, or imprisonment when voicing
discontent with the government in the past
two years.
State overreach is also the fear in Russia,
as the Moscow metro has implemented a new
method of payment at over 240 stations called
Face Pay.
As the program’s name suggests, Moscow commuters
can now leave their phone and wallet at home
and simply smile for the camera to board the
train.
In a country where governmental transparency
is hard to come by and facial recognition
has been allegedly used to identify protestors,
Face Pay has human rights groups and dubious
citizens concerned by the project’s potential
ulterior motives.
In another former Soviet state, government
officials made a statement as to where their
current allegiances lie when they kicked out
an outspoken US, Russian dual national.
Receiving a letter notifying he was barred
from entry into Kazakhstan, Gene Bunin, who
founded a victims database to track the incarceration
of Uyghurs in western China, serves as an
example as to how closely Kazakhstan has come
to align itself with China, not only turning
a blind eye to the what the US and UN have
come to define as genocide, but now seemingly
helping to quiet dissent within its own borders.
While some bonds are strengthening in Central
Asia, others in the Pacific are beginning
to crumble.
The result of a vote on the new secretary
general for the Pacific Islands Forum was
the last straw for the tiny Micronesian country
of Palau who announced they’d be leaving
the organization.
The coalition long had an informal tradition
of rotating its secretary general position
between Micronesian, Polynesian, and Melanesian
politicians, but the election of a Cook Islands
politician was a break from convention that
left Micronesian nations like Palau, and other
small island states that would follow their
lead, feeling slighted and voiceless in the
organization’s proceedings.
Trophy hunting of large carnivores is banned
in Romania but that didn’t stop Prince Emanuel
von und zu Liechtenstein of Austria from shooting
the country’s, and potentially the European
Union’s, single largest brown bear.
While the prince had authorization from the
Romanian government to hunt a female nuisance
bear causing problems for a small farm town,
he managed to bag the massive 17-year-old
Arthur—whether by accident or intentionally
is under investigation.
In another mountainous eastern European country,
construction crews put the finishing touches
on a state-of-the-art highway that cuts through
rugged Montenegro.
Rather than celebrating though, residents
are beginning to ask questions about the road’s
$1 billion price tag—the road only connects
a few small communities including the town
at its terminus, Matesevo, home to a population
of 15.
An early Belt and Road project built by Chinese
crews, Montenegro’s finances are now seriously
strained by the road that really doesn’t
serve much of a purpose.
The people of Brunei are hoping for more sage
decision-making from the new CEO of the nation’s
largest financial institution, Bank Islam
Brunei Darussalam.
Hjh Noriani will be the first female CEO of
the bank that manages $10 billion of assets
and has expanded across Southeast Asia and
into the Middle East in recent years.
After naming three women to top positions
in 2019, the move follows an empowering trend
at the bank in the traditionally conservative
country.
In Argentina, a 30-year-old confirmed an age-old
maxim: if it’s too good to be true, it usually
is.
Searching for an explanation for a momentary
Google outage, Nicolas Kuroña found that
the domain google.com.ar had expired and that
he could buy it for a modest $2.60.
The Argentine quickly scooped up the domain
that, if everything broke his way, could be
worth millions.
The domain didn’t prove a golden ticket
though, but a mistake as Google’s ownership
hadn’t lapsed, and in the end, Kuroña came
out of the situation a few dollars lighter.
In a country that’s been in the headlines
for all the wrong reasons the past few years
has emerged a more positive story.
Rolls-Royce and Qatar announced a multi-year,
multi-billion-dollar partnership aimed to
foster green technology companies.
The partnership will build two campuses, one
in each country; create an estimated 1,000
jobs; and hopefully provide the resources
and facilities for sustainability-oriented
startups to take off.
Prošek and Prosecco are two different types
of wine with two different names.
Just how different the names are though, has
Croatia and Italy at loggerheads.
Croatia has sought to trademark the name of
their Prošek with the European Commission
under the assumption that consumers would
be able to differentiate it from Italian Prosecco.
Italian wine aficionados think differently
and are fighting the move on account of potential
confusion.
Italians also see the effort as an attack
on Italian products more broadly, as Prosecco
is a denomination of controlled origin–a
wine that only comes from a specific region.
The world’s largest mammal, the blue whale,
only feeds in a few specific regions—one
of which is off the coast of Chilean Patagonia.
Unfortunately for the endangered species,
the water is also teeming with fishing vessels
working the busy salmon farming industry,
with up to 1,000 boats a day passing through
the feeding grounds.
This traffic has led to a handful of fatal
collisions between boat and blue whale.
With the regional population estimated to
be only in the hundreds, conservationists
are scrambling to figure out a compromise
that gives the whales a bit more room.
Bahrain is keen on finding a bit more room,
too.
So keen, in fact, that the archipelago nation
announced plans to expand its landmass by
60%.
The island-building initiative will enlarge
Bahrain’s footprint, construct five new
cities, and, the government hopes, attract
billions in foreign investment.
The project is set to build out tourist attractions,
a “sport city,” and a commercial zone.
From sport cities to sports washing, it was
a big year for professional athletics in Saudi
Arabia.
After its high-profile, highly controversial
takeover of Newcastle United, the country
also announced a partnership between Golf
Saudi and the Asian Tour that’ll keep a
Saudi stop on Asia’s preeminent golf circuit
and provide prize funding for a decade to
come.
While a quieter development than the Newcastle
deal, many denounced the move as another attempt
to move conversation and attention away from
the country’s human rights record with glitz
and games.
Issues with human rights records will be impossible
to miss if the Chinese Fudan University is
to follow through with building a campus in
Budapest, Hungary.
A majority of the city’s population oppose
the project and the city’s mayor has called
it an instance of “Chinese influence-buying.”
Residents are becoming increasingly creative
in their pushback, recently renaming nearby
streets Uyghur Martyrs’, Dalai Lama, and
Free Hong Kong Road.
One car skipped the streets entirely on its
way from the Nitra airport in Slovakia to
that in Bratislava.
Instead, the prototype flew the 35-minute
route.
For Klein Vision’s “Aircar,” it was
the 142nd landing, but an important first,
too, as the car successfully transitioned
into normal car mode in just minutes.
While behind on the timeline that science-fiction
authors envisioned, flying cars are slowly
coming around with Klein, Hyundai, and GM
leading the way.
Portugal’s parliament pushed into the future
of labor when it passed progressive measures
to protect its increasingly online workforce.
In response to the shift to working from home,
new laws bar employers from contacting employees
during off-hours, allow parents of children
under eight to work from home without bosses’
approval, and require employers to pitch in
on employees’ electricity costs.
The move comes in response to the pandemic,
but also as an effort to protect Portugal’s
reputation as an attractive place for digital
nomads to set up shop.
A finding in the remains of a different sort
of nomad in Latvia cast doubt on previous
theories as to the dramatic decline of stone-age
peoples across western Europe 5,000 years
ago.
DNA analysis of a hunter-gatherer showed the
man died of the plague, making him the earliest
victim of what was thought to have caused
the mysterious population decline.
Analysis, however, also showed that the strain
he carried didn’t spread easily and caused
milder symptoms than iterations that would
follow.
Now, rather than plague, scientists are looking
at climate change as a catalyst.
Successful Spanish YouTubers are making like
wealthy bankers and professional athletes
before them and running to the hills of Andorra.
One Spanish creator called Andorra the “Silicon
Valley of YouTube,” as the country has quickly
developed into a creative meeting place luring
in the like-minded with light taxes, relative
anonymity, and less stringent lockdown policies.
The move has been a boon for Andorra’s sputtering
economy, and a real loss for Spain’s, where
local media has gone so far as to call Spanish
YouTubers relocating unpatriotic.
A sputtering economy, many feel, would be
the result should Poland pivot away from coal.
Currently 70% of the country’s energy comes
from the non-renewable super-polluter, and
coal companies and miner unions hold serious
political power.
But Poland’s appetite and the massive strip
mine on its border are running Czech wells
dry, or at least so the Czech Republic accuses.
Citing European environmental laws, the Czech
Republic has sued Poland, setting off a wave
of conspiracy theories across coal country.
Conspiratorial might seem like a good way
to describe Lithuania’s defense ministry
calling for citizens to throw their Chinese-made
cell phones away.
The request, though, comes after the nation’s
cyber security center found that the Xiomi
Corp, a Chinese phone-maker, have censor technology
built into devices that track 449 terms including
the likes of “free Tibet,” and “democracy
movement.”
The finding comes as relationships between
China and Lithuania sour over Taiwan.
One internationally recognized state, one
defiant self-identifying state, two UK military
bases, and one UN buffer zone to keep the
peace hint at Cyprus' geopolitical complexity.
Things didn’t get any simpler in 2021 when
Turkish President Erdoğan announced that
in celebration of the 47th anniversary of
Turkey invading the island, the country planned
to resettle an abandoned, and formerly Greek
Cypriot tourist town.
Celebrating an invasion with a different sort
of invasion has received poor marks from the
US, the UN, and Greek Cypriots.
While heated geopolitical relations, and politicians’
hot air pose a threat in the Mediterranean,
so too does literal heat.
Greece, particularly vulnerable to climate
change generally, and especially heatwaves,
has decided to begin to name the extreme bouts
of heat.
Categorizing heatwaves is tricky, but any
standardization will allow the country to
better systematically respond to temperature
upticks and communicate the danger.
2021 marked the end of the Free Latifa campaign,
as the movement hatched three years ago finally
saw its vision come to fruition.
Princess Latifa was captured by her father,
Dubai’s Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid al-Maktoum,
when trying to express a little self-determination
and leave the United Arab Emirates.
She had hardly been seen in the past three
years but it seems her confinement came to
an abrupt end as an Instagram photo showed
the princess traveling in Iceland and a verifiable
statement quoted her saying she could now
“travel where I want.”
Italian motorcyclists and golfers can now,
within reason, travel where they want, too,
and do so in style.
The historic Italian car company, Iso, is
relaunching with a young backer from a famed
lineage leading the way.
Catching the company up with the present and
charging it into the future, Ferruccio Lamborghini
and team are launching a motorcycle and golf
cart that are modern, stylish, and sustainable—both
vehicles are completely electric.
A scarecrow of the seas may help to save the
lives of thousands of seabirds each year thanks
to researchers in Estonia who helped develop
a buoy with googly eyes.
The device floats above small-scale fishing
operation gill nets, which can be lethal to
diving seabirds, and deters them from coming
near.
In fact, scientists found it reduced the congregating
birds by about a quarter who are turned off
by eye contact and erratic buoy behavior.
Another sort of deterrent is the addition
of Malta to an international greylist kept
by Financial Action Task Force, a watchdog
organization meant to monitor money laundering
and terrorism funding.
In recent years, the island nation’s low
tax rate for foreign companies has attracted
substantial banking and investment, but that
also makes it ripe for abuse.
It’s the first European Union nation to
be listed, and could potentially affect the
upward trajectory of Malta as wealthy investors
look to alternate locations given its now-tenuous
nature.
One of Europe’s wealthiest people and the
Czech Republic’s richest man, Peter Kellner,
was tragically killed in a helicopter crash
while heli-skiing in Alaska, along with four
additional passengers.
Kellner was estimated to be worth $17.5 billion,
and his death follows a string of recent fatal
high-profile helicopter accidents including
Kobe Bryant and French billionaire Olivier
Dassault.
On the coast, France and the United Kingdom
finally settled some post-Brexit bickering
over fishing.
France wanted the British government to issue
a number of fishing licenses to small French
boats so they could continue harvesting in
British waters, and the Brits stalled, citing
a number of technicalities from the French
side.
The issue simmered to a threat-of-trade-sanctions
level, but cooler heads prevailed, an agreement
was met, and 83 fishing licenses were assigned
before it reached a boiling point.
Another agreement was reached in Spain, but
this one pertains to many people’s go-to
source for the day’s headlines: Google news.
Banned from the country for six years because
Spain required Google to pay a central fee
to media organizations for use of their stories,
the new law now allows Google parent company,
Alphabet, to negotiate directly with publishers
for content.
Now, more than 1,000 Spanish media organizations
can be sourced for news from a single smartphone.
Speaking of smartphones, it may have gone
unnoticed in your Apple-happy world, but South
Korean manufacturer LG announced its departure
from the phone market.
Once ranked only behind Apple and Samsung
for smartphone manufacturing, the company
said a series of bad reviews and technical
rollouts prompted it to shift its focus to
other areas, such as connected devices for
the home, robotics, and artificial intelligence.
LG joins Ericsson and HTC in the cell phone
graveyard.
Smart is also the way to describe Amazon’s
accountants.
The company had a record-breaking 2020 in
Europe, hauling in some $50 billion, but it
managed to pay zero in corporate taxes to
Luxembourg, home to its European headquarters.
Of course, it’s all legal, but when a company
not only doesn’t pay anything, but also
declares losses which result in tax credits,
to the tune of $63 million, there is some
definite eye-rolling and belt-tightening from
policymakers looking to benefit from the boom.
The government in Slovenia is running an alleged
crusade against culture, with Prime Minister
Janez Jansa replacing the heads of several
arts organizations in what some are calling
a shift to more conservative approaches.
Jansa, who had served twice in the role prior
to being ousted for corruption, named new
leaders for the National Museum, the Museum
of Contemporary History, and the Moderna Galerija,
and he continues to terminate leases from
arts organizations that rent space from the
government.
He denies that it’s an orchestrated movement,
but for many, it’s hard to paint over the
facts.
Low government limitations have led to a hot
streak of gambling development in Lichtenstein,
one of the world’s smallest countries, now
home to five casinos.
That may sound like a so-so number, but it
puts its per capita above Monaco, Macau, and
Las Vegas’ Clark County.
One reason?
The gambling tax rate is lower than in neighboring
countries, and the government there hasn’t
set caps on the number of casinos that can
be built.
Five more are in the pipeline, which means
the foreign investors largely responsible
for them are betting big on the future.
Tensions are rising between Japan and the
tandem of China and Russia.
While they’ve been escalating for years
because of Beijing’s increased presence
on islands controlled by Japan but claimed
by Russia, they hit a new high when a 10-ship
Chinese-Russian flotilla circumnavigated Japan’s
main island this summer.
China and Russia say it was merely a diplomatic
exercise, but Japan is worried a threatening
presence means it will need to increase defense
spending and be more on guard.
Spying seems to be a trend, but the United
States told Israel they don’t want to play
that game.
Israeli spyware maker NSO Group was placed
on an American blacklist after it was reasonably
confirmed that NSO’s signature product,
Pegasus, was used by foreign governments against
dissidents, journalists, diplomats, and clergy
members.
The blacklisting means, among other things,
that NSO won’t be able to buy components
from US companies for its products—something
Apple is ensuring after suing the group this
year as well.
Austrian tourism officials want to encourage
viewing of the country’s nude sculptures
and paintings that pepper museums, but social
media platforms’ censorship policies have
made their promotion difficult.
So Vienna did what anyone trying to get around
the no-private-parts policy would do: they
opened an account on the adults-only app OnlyFans.
Many of the works are critical to national
cultural history, and now they’re free to
promote the exhibitions without that fuzzy
bar.
2021 wasn’t all spying, censorship, and
general contention, there were positive developments
too: United States-based dictionary.com named
“allyship” its word of the year.
Officially added to dictionary.com in 2021,
“allyship” rose in popularity during the
Black Lives Matter movements across the world
but its definition makes clear that its applications
are even farther-reaching.
One says, "the role of a person who advocates
for inclusion of a marginalized or politicized
group in solidarity but not as a member.”
More word searches means there’s certainly
more of this going on.
This is a story about the good guy winning,
but this time, it’s a lobster.
A Canadian grocer noticed that no one was
purchasing a certain carrot-colored crustacean,
and on top of that, it was being picked on
by other lobsters in the tank.
After several weeks he bought the lobster
himself and donated it to the Toronto Aquarium,
where it was discovered his strange hue was
a one-in-30 million genetic mutation.
Pinchy, the lobster, avoided the plate and
now has a more permanent, public home.
In an effort to speed up the development of
more home building in New Zealand, to combat
the 30% increase in housing cost and shortage
of inventory, officials are cutting red tape
and making it easier for developers to address
a housing crisis so dire that it’s drawn
international attention.
Specifically they’re changing some density
regulations, allowing for up to three homes
of three stories on one site versus one home
of two stories, a move that some predict will
erect 48,000 to 106,000 new homes in the next
five to eight years.
Expansion is something that a Belgian farmer
accidentally did when he moved a several-hundred
pound stone seven feet into France.
The historic markers delineate the borders
between the two countries, and a team of Frenchmen
who patrol the remote countryside verifying
the positions noticed the errant stone.
Luckily, the farmer wasn’t charged with
violating the international treaty that certifies
the border—a crime that could have resulted
in a territorial war instead of a slap on
the wrist.
To the north, the United Kingdom is rapidly
trying to make up for centuries of contributing
to climate change.
To that end, it launched the world’s most
powerful tidal turbine off the Port of Dundee,
creating enough electricity for 2,000 homes,
and Rolls Royce announced the development
of 16 smaller, cheaper nuclear power plants
to electrify 1 million homes.
Britain is already one of the largest wind-energy
producers in the world–not bad for the country
that started the Industrial Revolution.
Have you heard of Grab or a SPAC?
In this story, we have both.
Grab is a Singapore-based superapp that offers
everything from ride sharing to banking in
one tap.
SPAC is a special purpose acquisition company,
an investment strategy in which a larger company
merges with a publicly-traded shell company
in order to expedite going public.
Grab signed a $39.5 billion merger deal with
a US SPAC, which brought the company public
on the NASDAQ stock exchange on December 2nd.
That makes it the largest-ever deal of its
kind, and means we should pay attention to
both SPACs and Grab ASAP.
Finland has a lot going for it, including
being named the happiest country in the world
for the fourth consecutive year.
But, one thing it can’t nail is labor retention,
and, in fact one study shows a major reason
foreign students leave Helsinki within their
first year of graduating is the language barrier.
These difficulties prompted the mayor to suggest
transitioning the capital city to speaking
English primarily.
That may help employment, but TBD on happiness.
We’ve talked a lot about ways to create
green energy.
Another way to fight climate change is by
consuming less meat, and Denmark is leading
the European Union in this effort by giving
$90 million to farmers who produce plant-based
foods over the next five years.
The country eats a lot of pork, but the sale
of plant-based food there has increased by
$8 million in two years.
Pigs might not fly, and they might not be
the only thing on the menu anymore either.
Just to the southwest, officials in the Netherlands
unveiled a plan to reduce the country’s
livestock by about 1/3 over the next 13 years.
But it’s for a different reason: there’s
too much poop.
The country has more than 100 million cattle,
chickens, and pigs—the highest density in
Europe—and can’t quite contain their waste
without polluting important waterways.
Farmers, naturally, are pushing back, even
though the multi-billion dollar plan intends
to pay them to essentially exit the industry.
Maybe they can jump on Denmark’s plant-based
patty-wagon.
Also planning for the future is the 2032 Olympic
committee, and specifically, Australia.
It was announced that Brisbane will be the
host of the summer games in 10 years, and
what’s notable about this selection isn’t
the place, but the process.
Instead of expensive, competitive, and often
corrupt bidding wars pitting cities against
one another, bids are now submitted and then
reviewed behind closed doors by selection
committees.
In this case, the best mate won.
In Sweden, Magdalena Andersson won but wasn’t
too happy with her first day on the job.
So, the Swedish prime minister resigned just
12 hours in because the junior Green party
also quit, throwing her coalition into chaos.
She indicated she’d lead a Social Democrat
single-party and was reelected a week later,
becoming the first female prime minister of
Sweden—for a second time.
The second time was not as successful for
a criminal in Germany, whose first crime involved
a burglary in 2012.
He got away with that one and a bite of a
sausage, which left behind some DNA evidence
that police held onto.
Fast forward to today when he committed a
more violent crime and the genetic residue
linked him to the decade-old heist through
an international information-sharing library.
However, the statute of limitations expired
and he’s gone free, proving there’s no
bite out of crime this time.
So we’re five from the end, and the truth
is, a lot of headlines you missed are about
the ways these recent, more developed countries
are adapting and attacking climate change.
Iceland started operating the world’s first
direct air capture technology, which turns
CO2 into rock.
But perhaps more quirky is that the country
also performed the world’s first double
arm-and-shoulder transplant to replace the
limbs a man lost in a work accident more than
two decades prior.
Progress on the micro and the macro level
is something to high-five about.
Now a quick disclaimer before this next story:
the UN lists 189 HDI scores, and while a vast
majority of those scores correlate to countries,
the UN makes sure to acknowledge their list
is a compilation of “189 countries and UN-recognized
territories.”
We have now arrived at the only territory
on their list, and while technically not a
country, we figured the more news the better,
so we’ve gone ahead and included the Chinese
territory of Hong Kong.
Disney+ finally launched in Hong Kong in 2021
and while much of the streaming service’s
content provides a needed escape from the
chaos and confusion that’s embroiled the
Chinese territory in the past few years, one
omission from the Simpson’s catalog hints
at just how inescapable the tension has become.
Noticeably absent was episode 12 of season
16 that has the Simpson family visiting China
and specifically Tiananmen square, and while
minor for plot purposes, its disappearance
signals the increasing reach of government
censorship into the traditionally independent
city.
The Swiss are notoriously on time, but they
were late to join the same-sex marriage party.
The country finally approved a “Marriage
for All” initiative with two-thirds voting
in favor, becoming one of the last Western
European countries to do so.
Switzerland, known for neutrality, is slow
on inclusivity issues and didn’t allow women
the right to vote until 1971.
So this, though sluggish in adoption, is a
cultural win.
It also took a while for Irish authorities
to come down on enforcing the European Union’s
three-year-old General Data Protection Regulation,
which is a comprehensive data privacy law.
But, they served Meta’s Whatsapp with a
$270 million fine for not being transparent
on how it uses people’s data across the
company’s platforms.
Many tech company’s headquarters are based
in Ireland, where corporate tax rates are
low, so there may be more cases like this—which
of course is being contested by Whatsapp—to
come.
And finally, it feels appropriate to end on
a note that reminds us about the scale of
humanity.
In Norway, a large meteor lit up the summer
night sky for five to six seconds before,
in all likelihood, crashing into a densely
wooded area about 40 miles, or 60 kilometers,
west of the country’s capital.
Some people reported a strong wind created
by the pressure from it, and while it may
take years to find its physical remains, the
blazing meteor, for a fleeting moment, captured
the attention of thousands of onlookers–a
rare instance of singularity in an ever-individual
world.
Of course, the news doesn’t stop with Norway,
nor does it end with the end of the year.
But you don’t have to wait for us to highlight
interesting stories that may have fallen through
the cracks–sign up for Morning Brew for
free today and they’ll deliver these stories
straight to your inbox each and every morning.
If you’re interested in business, tech,
or finance, or you’re simply trying to clean
up a morning routine that has you endlessly
scrolling through social media, then Morning
Brew and its informative, quick, witty newsletters
are for you.
It’s certainly for me too, look no further
than my story from Portugal.
All the information I needed to outline Portugal’s
unique work from home legislation was available
in a quick 3-minute read put together by Morning
Brew.
Of course, Morning Brew doesn’t just provide
fodder for YouTube or content, it keeps me
informed on the everyday going-ons–from
the main points on Biden’s most recent statement
on the pandemic to important statistics on
America’s current birth rate and its future
impact on the economy.
The newsletter is completely free, it takes
less than 15 seconds to subscribe, and you
can stay on top of the news by clicking the
button on-screen or following the link in
the description below.